you've also mentioned about body count
you guys both have a high body count
does body count matter or depends like
like you said it's low in some people's
eyes it's high in other people's eyes
does body count matter in relationships
it's the past matter
well the past matters I don't think body
count not to me I don't really care not
just as it is no yeah
I mean the past does yeah well the past
is who you are right like somebody tells
me like they have a 200 body count and
they're 16. something's probably going
on there that's not good I was thinking
about that too like because it could be
like really young people that are having
some sort of like mental yeah that's
going on or somebody's like 45 and
they've like never had sex before
there's probably something going on
right so they could be indicative but if
somebody's like in their 20s and they've
had sex with you know 100 people or
affiliate people whatever it's you know
whatever there's more experience which
can be good sure okay so that that just
represents your like sexually open and
so it doesn't really necessarily mean
any kind of not necessarily it could
though the number alone doesn't mean
anything yeah okay well you could meet a
guy that's like I just really really
like want to [ __ ] a lot of people
because it makes me so cool like you
give me someone like that which is like
the body count doesn't matter but like
where it comes from like yeah like why
why have you slept with the people you
slept with yes does it hurt like the
Romantic aspect the relationship knowing
that there's a lot of people in the past
I don't know not for us no is a part of
the relationship fundamentally romantic
for us yeah okay
what you come up with such a cold person
no I was just in my head thinking and I
wanted to just say gotcha right there
it's so judgmental I think when it comes
to the sex thing there's always like the
way that I explain it is and I
understand like
um I have to say this because I don't
advocate for what I do for everybody or
what she does for everybody because
obviously there's a whole bunch of
natural feelings of jealousy that pop up
for a lot of people
um but when people ask me you know it's
always like oh like isn't this like
horrible that you guys are doing this
and you don't love each other from my
perspective I can have sex with like any
person and it can be sex like that's not
like a special thing between two people
in my eyes it's like anybody can have
sex but there are like certain
activities and ways you can spend time
with each other where you're like
carving out these like precious little
moments in time with a certain person
that can do things that are special to
that person and those are the kind of
like events that I remember more than
anything else so like the idea of like
like oh wow I had sex with a person that
was so special doesn't mean as much as
like you know us traveling to like New
Zealand or sharing some special moment
doing like some really fun activity or
event or whatever that's usually how I
like it I am so a shared intimate moment
yeah I kind of agree but I can
definitely connect the romance with sex
boring I'm curious
it's exactly we've also talked about
misogyny which is you're clearly the
embodiment of that what were you saying
so there's some there's a connection
between romance and yeah I think it is
because I think sex could be a lot of
things right
it's it's some sort of bonding I'd say
in some way they say that you really
like BDSM you kind of like you become
submissive to someone or you take
control over someone it's like in a very
bonding like intimate moment I'd say and
that's romantic the intimacy is romantic
I I think it is if you can show yourself
it's really submissive or like weak when
you have like absolutely no control over
yourself and you let someone else do it
or you are the one being that like you
are the dominant for someone I think
that's a really like intimate thing
because you show like the weakest Part
of Yourself kind of I just feel like I
personally
to me some component romantic but to me
this is not judging to others to Me
Maybe it's how I was brought up
the romance increases if the number of
intimate interactions are limited to one
person
like for me for some reason
spreading it out
decreases like
um exponentially the the feeling of
romance you feel or that I don't know
what that could be just like sort of
having grown up in the Soviet Union
there's a kind of there's the fairy tale
stories and you're kind of maybe living
through them
yeah I mean I think what you're saying
is like really normal like most people
probably feel that way yeah but but
because you guys are able to
successfully not do that I just want to
question my own understanding of it you
know like like why is that why is that
why am I being very um jealous for no
reason like maybe you can maximize the
number of intimate experiences if you
just open up and let go of the jealousy
essentially I think I feel like in
Sweden like in Scandinavia we're
extremely just sexually open like in
general we're not like super religious
either we're very like relaxed we don't
like we don't feel bad about ourselves
like it's just like a different sort of
thing and I would say like it's we're
more Progressive when it comes to
feminism and stuff so it's more common
they will meet women with a higher body
count than like when I meet like
American Girls all of them I have like
vaginous smell like super suppressed
like sexually and they're like what did
you just use they have like issues to
like they can't relax during sex which
is hers for them
isn't that what it's called yeah
um so like I meet so many girls that are
having like a lot of issues with sex and
they have like a very low body count
because they just can't relax or they
yeah and it's probably and usually they
come from like a very religious
background
um so they have just been told like you
cannot wear that you cannot be like that
you can't like you know and like where I
grew up it was not like that at all but
you see it as more like a casual thing
so then you can just maximize
the awesomeness of the experience yeah I
guess
exactly am I think the important thing I
think for everybody to realize is
there's always pros and cons to
everything like my lifestyle like
obviously I get to have a lot of fun
experiences that's like a huge Pro and
that's super cool and if you're like a
more monogamy-brained person you're not
going to get those experiences but if
you're a monogamy brain person like when
you're sharing that special moment of
time with somebody else like that moment
can be really really really special
because now it's the thing that you're
showing yourself and opening yourself up
to another person and they're only
trusting you to do that and that's like
a really special thing that only the two
of you are sharing with each other so I
mean like there's always like pros and
cons to everything like I think we both
would say like like doing an open
relationship is probably not like we
would not recommend it yeah I don't
think we would no
yeah recently fasted for three days and
I ate a chicken breast at the end of
that and it was like the most delicious
food I've ever eaten so like there's
some aspect of fasting and scarcity and
so on that like and you have to figure
out what for your own psyche what works
the best it's good to be a little bored
or like not do something or like work
because you can just enjoy the time when
you're doing something really fun it's
more fun otherwise you're just gonna get
numb in general with everything yeah
yeah I personally just never get bored
like I guess the boring thing is
exciting to me the just like you're like
me because everything I like is boring